So part two of our discussion of the absolutely
dystopian Trump rally in Tulsa, Oklahoma,
over the weekend is the attendees.
Yes, there weren't that many of them, despite
their predictions.
And we're going to talk about that later on.
But check out some of these interviews with
people who went there to support Donald Trump
now.
Now, I do feel the need to issue a disclaimer
here.
The goal here isn't to make fun of people.
The goal is to remind you some of these people
vote, not all of them, but some of these people
vote.
And when I explain week after week after week
why it's so important to get out the vote
in November.
This is going to remind us of the importance,
because a ton of these Trump busts, when you
see them talk, you're going to realize that
what I've been saying is true.
They can't be talked out of voting for Donald
Trump.
These are the people that we are talking about.
When I say, would it be easier to get five
leftist friends to vote, people who are not
usually voters and just say, hey, it's really
important that you vote.
Would that be easier or would it be easier
to convince one of these people?
I'm about to show you to vote and you will
very quickly see.
These are not people you can talk sense into.
So the context here, remember, is Corona virus
is spreading wildly in Oklahoma and other
red states.
A huge part of the country doesn't seem to
believe it or believe that it's that serious
or believe that it warrants social distancing.
And a lot of those exact same people are the
ones that approve of the job that Donald Trump
is doing, the one saying, I like what he's
doing.
I believe he's doing a good job.
So let's start with Rosie Matlock.
Check this out.
She waited in line for four days.
Remember, the stadium was two thirds empty.
Why you would wait in line for four days anyway
is a question why you would do it when the
stadium is two thirds empty.
Well, she was propagandized by Donald Trump
about a million requests for tickets and she
was interviewed by Andrew Kimmel.
This is fascinating.
She's asked, why have you been sleeping in
the chair for four days waiting for Trump?
And she says, well, he risked his whole life
for us.
So I'm here, which almost suggests she's agreeing
that there is a risk to her life from being
at the rally.
Right.
Maybe I'm missing the interpretation here,
but let's take a look at it together from
and see when when did you start waiting in
line?
Wednesday.
So what brought you to come out on Wednesday?
I want to see my friend.
And are you sleeping out here?
You've been sleeping in a chair.
That is devotion.
And so you know what?
What is it that makes you want to sleep on
the street?
Sit in a chair for three nights.
Now he's risk everything.
He.
Right.
How about that for an answer?
Are you leaving behind one more negative?
So that's weird.
And this next moment is just great.
This is still Andrew Kimmel interviewing her.
Rosie Matlock's says what could get you to
not vote for Trump?
In other words, is there a hypothetical where
if Trump did X, X would mean you don't vote
for Trump?
And she says, well, if he cheated on Melania,
which, of course, Donald Trump did.
And check out the direction this goes.
Is there anything that Trump can do that would
make you lose your support for.
Commit adultery on a classy wife.
She's amazing.
She is what every American first lady should
be.
Well, what about the Stormy Daniels thing?
Because he was married to her at that time.
That was years ago before he ever became president.
Nobody is accountable for what he'd done when
he was a lot younger.
Oh, okay. Trump was cheating on Melania, but
when he was in his 60s.
Now Trump is president as a 70 plus year old
man.
You can't hold him accountable for that.
This is gold because we often talk about asking
Trump is this question, what would make you
not support Trump?
She identifies something that would make her
not support Trump cheating on Melania and
Andrew Kimmo points out.
Well, but but he did that and she says, well,
yeah, but that was before he was president
of the United States.
If he cheated on Melania.
Now, I wouldn't vote for him.
You cannot convince them.
Do not even bother.
Do not waste your time.
Please, let's continue.
Here's a Trump list inside the rally.
Asked about virus concerns, says he's not
worried because he he can always take hydroxyl
chloroquine.
Take a look.
I'm not concerned about the spread.
I think in the general population, I'm saying
knock.
Point four point two percent mortality rate.
And if you're not a good guy, you're not worried
about no.
And even if I did get sick from it.
I mean, there's so many positive studies with
the Hydra for clean and zinc.
Today, the FDA got written.
He said he can't prescribe it for them.
I know the FBI is saying that it is able to
be prescribed.
They only shut it down for a certain for a
certain thing.
And actually and Trump's roundtable the other
day.
They explained it very well.
So, of course, this guy is wrong.
The emergency use authorization was shut down.
Patients on hydroxyl chloroquine were not
doing well.
It's not working.
And what happened in the roundtable is that
Alix's are simply said it might work if taken
earlier.
We don't have any evidence of that.
But that's what was said at the roundtable.
So, again, important.
These folks don't even comprehend what it
is.
That is said Alex.
Azar was lying when he said this stuff.
In other words, the idea that they're optimistic
about giving it earlier, there is no evidence
of that.
But it doesn't matter because people like
this voter will hear whatever it is that they
want to hear.
Here's another dude who has a friend who died
of Corona virus.
His friends kid was on a ventilator, but here
he is without a mask around people without
masks as Casey's rage in Oklahoma.
Take a look.
I know his real friend who died from Colvard
and his son was on a ventilator.
He almost died.
So we know it's real.
But then at the same time, you know, you don't
know what the facts, you know, because you
feel like maybe one side plays it one way
and the other side places another.
So me personally, I don't really know.
I do know ones that are very concerned about
it.
Well, when we spent time with them last five
days, they were they were interacting without
their masks.
His friend died.
Son on a ventilator almost died.
But we don't know what the facts are.
Well, what what are we talking about exactly?
I mean, is it a fact that your friend died?
Is it a fact that your friend's kid was on
a ventilator?
And then the motivated reasoning is just fascinating.
Listen, I know people who are concerned and
they're around groups of people without wearing
a mask.
So that must be evidence.
That's OK.
That it's OK to do the thing I want to do
anyway.
But are we talking about that being done at
a rally of 60, 200 people?
That seems a little different.
And then here's the cherry on top.
Here's a guy who says that Barack Obama ushered
in Marxism and says, how on earth did anyone
vote for anyone named Obama anyway?
Oh, and by the way, Obama also wasn't Obama's
real name supporter.
And what drew you to him?
And why were you always a conservative Republican?
I walked away from the Republicans back in
2006 once we gave them a trifecta from 04
to 06.
They spent like drunken sailors and they became,
you know, basically Democrats.
So I walked away from them back then, you
know, didn't they?
You know, half the country's wealth was stolen
in broad daylight, you know, September of
09.
Nobody goes to jail except Bernie Madoff.
And he was stealing from his own people.
Then, of course, they ushered in Obama to
normalize Marxism in the United States of
America.
She ended up for Hillary to do a sin.
You know, I just think it'd be common sense
she wouldn't vote for a guy named Obama for
president of the United States, particularly
since I wasn't even his real name.
But, you know, Marxist Obama, whose real name
wasn't Obama, never should have been elected
on the basis of claiming to be named Barack
Obama.
It's interesting.
If you're going to lie about your name, wouldn't
you pick something that would not be a turnoff
to a large swath of this country that is xenophobic
and racist and pick something other than Barack
Obama, like as a fake name?
Barack Obama seems like a horrible idea.
Seems Martin Smith might have been a smarter
fake name to take if that was the idea.
So we can't convince them this is more proof.
We've got to get out the vote.
Don't even waste energy.
Just focus on getting out the vote in the
key battleground in swing states.
We know which ones they are.
We know which states are likely to determine
who is the Electoral College Victor in November.
And that's where we have to focus.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
Remember that we have a daily audio podcast
which you can get for free on any of your
favorite podcasting apps.
Leave us, sir.
Review, if you please.
On I.
ITunes, Stitcher, Spotify.
Pick your poison.
All of them are available.
We'll take a quick break.
More on the rally attendance and Trump's rage
at the empty seats coming up after the break.